[音楽]
ブードゥー君
えーとこれは私が15歳の時の写真です
この頃私はいろいろな悩みを抱えていてですね
a 今でいう
ひきこもり不登校になっておりました
今思いますとその時の悩みというのはですね
人間って何だろう自分って何だろう
自分は特別な存在なんだろうかというようないですねちょっと哲学的なですねえっと
原因も
流ではなかったかというように思いますそれでですね科学者になった後ですねえっと
先ほどのような疑問をですねじゃあ科学的に解明するにはどうしたらいいかというよう
なことを考えてきました科学の研究の大切な手法の一つにですね
威嚇するということがあります私の先ほどの疑問もですね
な
以下比較して答えを見つけることはできないかということを考えてきたわけです
では8一体何と何を比較したらいいか私たち人間と何を比較したらいいかということ
ですね
で a 考えたんですけれども
洋装の星人も人がいるかどうかつまり私たちの言葉でいうと地球外知的生命ですね地球
外知的生命が存在するかどうかということを解明する比較すればいいということが
a そういう結論になりました
つまりですねもしよそのほしいですねあな肉沢山の文明があってたくさんのですね
地球外の的生命が存在していたとすれば私たちは
願うそれほど特殊なものではないありふれた存在だということになるわけです
逆にこれはちょっと証明するがあの難しいというかほぼ不可能なんですけど仮にいる
もし我々だけがこの宇宙には我々だけ知的生命は我々酒ということになりましたら私た
ちっていうのは
唯一絶対的な存在ですよね本当にスペシャルな存在ということになるわけです
ということでですね私は地球外知的生命が存在するかどうか
あれはもしいたとしたらですねいるとすればどうやってどういう手法によって発見する
ことができるかというようなことですね追求してきました
ではまずですね素敵生命が存在するかどうかということについて考えたいと思いますが
その前に一つですね皆さんに入っていっただきたいことがありますこれから星と星の
距離とかそういう話をします星と星の距離っていうのは非常に離れておりますので
私たちが使っているキロメートルでやるとですね
0たくさん書かなきゃいけないそれだけでもね大変なので天文学で別の単位を使えます
それは何か
この世の中で一番スピードの速いものを基準といたしますこの世の中一番スピード速い
ものはもちろん光ですよね
光は1秒間に30万キロメートルねあっと進んでいきます
それが1年間
関係って飛んで行く距離べらぼうなも層増税する距離ですけどもこれを1つの単位と
いたしまして
これを1ly というように言いますじゃあ
8その1ly て私たちがよく使っている馴染みのあるキロメートルに直すと換算する
どういうことになるかちょっと実はですね
これだけけど目マルカブあの0数えなくていいです数えなくていいです
たっくさんだなと思ってくれたらそれでいいですよねあのこれからなんとかこう寝てて
いますからね0たくさんつけたら
km に観察するよということに思ってくださいそれでですねじゃあこのですね宇宙と
いうのは大きい望遠鏡を作れば作るほど遠くまで遠くまで見えるかというとそういう
わけでありません
もうそれ以上は絶対に見えないっていうところが出てきます
宇宙にもやはり地平線みたいなものがありますねこれが宇宙の地平線です
じゃあ私たちのそれも原理的に見えないやんですけども絶対見えません
ここからじゃあその宇宙の地平線まで何光年離れてます甲冑と実はこれが
これだけ公園
航空からなっちゃってよくわかってないんですけどおおよそ130か140個年くらい
だと言われておりますそれより向こうは絶対見えないんですけどじゃあその中に星構成
はいくつあるかといいますとこれが
8日の多いこと星の数って例えますけど本当の星の数ですよ本当の星の数でてますこれ
だけ高
これはどの公演に行ってもね皆さん笑うだけなんですよね
ちょっと想像図ですいますでしょ地球上のありとあらゆる
海岸にある砂の数をイメージしてみてください
その数よりまだ多いと言われています
それが宇宙です
これが結論ですよね
これだけあればどこかには存在するはずですこれだけをたくさんの
法事があって
知的生命が私たちだけだっていう考えになるとこれは中世ヨーロッパ暗黒時代のと同じ
ような考えね陥ってしまうのではないかというように思います
じゃあどうやって探したらいいかという話をねこれからいたします
こういうことがあり得るでしょうか
こういうこと母考える方はですねはっきり
私たちからね天文学者から言わせますと
宇宙の広さを
なめてかかってます
何でかって言いますと太陽拳一番近い方してじゃあ何光年でしょうかね
実は4ly です4光年って言われてもちょっと皆さんピンとこないかもしれないんで
宇宙全体を1000億分の1にしてみようと思いますね
するとどうなりますかね宇宙全体を
1000億分の1にするとですね実は太陽っていうのは地球の109倍の重さが大きさ
がありますその対応がですね実はこれになります
ビー玉ですねこれがえっと対応です本当黄色いです黄色いけどもまぁ今ちょっと青い奴
でね青い b だのであります
これをですねいいですかここに置きますよ
ここでもないしここでもないしねここに置きますねいいですか泊まっておいてください
ね
するとですねもう一つのビー玉がここにあるんですね
これが一番近いねえっと4光年先ノーね
星だと思うわけほんともこれは本当はこれも黄色いんですけど今はね
赤いやつでやります赤いビー玉でありますさあ
床に置くとちょうどいいスケールになると思うでしょうか
皆さんどう思います
こことかアソコとかアソコとかね
今日はちょっと答えをもう入ってしまいますけど答えはですねいいですか
東京です
ここに一つビーダーが送っておくと東京にまで行かないと次のビー玉は出てこないん
です
宇宙の星と星の音感覚というのはこういうもんです
ざっくり星と星の平均的な感覚こういうものです
もし皆さんがですね宇宙ってどういうところですかって聞かれたらですね模範的な回答
は
何もないところ
で答えるのが模範解答ですねたまーにポッド保持があるだけマシってや
ね知的生命が存在するほしいっても貼るか想像絶する彼方にあるはずです
ということでですね
こういうことは
絶対にありませんなんか乗り物にね乗ってやってくるということは絶対ねあないわけで
ございますつまりですね直接的に出合うことっていうのはまず
まずやって絶対無理ですじゃあどうするかでこれ間接的にね
調べるしかないんですかエラーが出している何かの関節が証拠を見つけましょうとこう
いうことしかありませんでよくやられているのがですねカエラが出している
電場をねキャッチしましょうということですねそれから金田がれレーザー光線を出して
いるかもしれない
そういうものをキャッチしましょうっていうね方この2つが魔王もな方法です
ちなみにこれうちのあの大学の天文台の望遠鏡ねじゃあそういったもの電波だとか
レーザー光線ってのはこの地球に本当にやってくるのかどうかだね
微弱ででやって来ないんじゃないって思うかもしれないんですけどもですね
あの向こうの音方々っていうかな知的生命が少なくとも地球人レベルであったとすると
ですね計算するとですね電波やレーザーは数千光年先からでもやってきた
レーザーや電波でも地球のはでキャッチすることができます
電波になりますで周波数によりますけれども周波数になるある種咲く花数だと1万光年
先からやってきた電波でも現在の地球のレベルでキャッチすることができるわけです
まあ根拠があるということをね知っておいてくださいではですね私が実際にやってきた
事本当にダイジェストでね紹介したいと思いますが私がいまいちは何をしてきたかと
いうと
今言ったように電波観測もしましたそれからですね
あこれがレーザーですねレーザーをキャッチするということもありました
どうするかというと普通の構成果たす光っていうのはどの色も均一に出ます
でももしですねレーザーきたら例えば緑のレーザーが向こうから来たるですね
虹の中に緑のところだけ光るわけです
グラフである場合猫そこだけピット切符強度が上がるわけです
なぁこういう感じねそれからですねそういうレーザー光線がもし来るとしたらですね
知的文明が出しているレーザー光線が来るとしたら
彼らは何色のレーザー光線を使っているだろうとかこの世界で初めてあの理論的に予測
しましてそういう論文もこれつい最近の話ですけども書きました
出しましたそれからですねある星をターゲット
にしてですね世界5大陸15各国29機関が合同でですね観測するとそういう
プロジェクトもですね私が主催いたしましてですね
総合本部ですねかっこいい言葉で言うとこれこれが私ねあの私があの仲裁したんで
かっこいい言葉でところ mission control center
もうちょっと平たく言うとこれ私のいつもの業務の付けなんですけども
まあそういうこともしれないですね
それからですねこの日本ではですねこの分野では一番大きいですね研究会をいたしまし
た
そういうのを称賛しましたでへともし見つかったらどうぞどう関係関係者はどう対応し
ていいかという実は国際的なガイドラインがあります
で現それがそのガイドラインがですね現在のこの時代に見合ったのかどうかっていうの
はですね検討して来たる
玖珠でに備えてですね心の準備をねしましたということです
じゃあそうやってね色々やりましたけれども
じゃあ見つかったのかこれが皆さん一番聞きたいことことだと思うんですけれどもこう
いう私のこういう観測研究を含めてですねえっと50年以上に渡りまして葉っぱのほか
の国も合わせてですよ
50年以上にわたって
100以上のプロジェクトが今までやるあの実施されていますが残念な子にですね
明確な証拠っていうのは今のところ
ありません残念ながらねじゃあそれを持ってしてですねやっぱり
じゃあいないんじゃないかとちゃん際しないんじゃないかそういうわけではないんです
まだたったの50人しか観測してないんです人類の歴史宇宙の歴史に比べたらほんの
僅かで例えるですね
例えればですね海の水をバケツでいっぱい作ってですねそこにですね
魚が入ってなかったからやっぱり海には魚がいないんじゃないかというようなねもの
じゃないでしょうか
でもこれ実は発見があったんですよね
海の水をバケツで一杯分すくってはそこには魚はいないというですね密度の魚の存在
する密度の中推定ができたわけです
つまりこれは大きな発見ですよ
つまりいっ
この雨で行くたくさんどこにでもですね存在するようなそういう存在ではなかなかない
だろう
結構珍しい存在だろうという発見があったんだと思います
じゃあ何でそんな珍しいなかなか値打ちが文明であふれているそういうわけではない
ですよそういうのはなぜかと言いますとですねこれし考えていますね
生命誕生しますねた細胞なる脊椎動物になって上陸して哺乳類になって霊長類なって
方向先祖様というかこれ全部ご先祖様ですけどね
あの大お盆になるとこういう方々が帰って来てるんですよ
来年からこういうのを迎えしないといけない
でいいですか40億年前生物が新
誕生してから私たちに行くこの過程はですね実は無数の偶然が重なっております沢山の
偶然があってここまで来ているわけですよ
例えばですねひとつわかりやすいでここからここね
哺乳類から霊長類
のところですココネ実は1億年前何億年前はでずっとこの状態でした我々のご先祖様
それ以上進化できませんでしたなぜですかそのとき地球を支配していたのは恐竜ですよ
彼らがし支配していたためにですね私たちのご先祖様はずっとこの状態だったんです
ところが恐竜が絶滅したから
哺乳類が敵を拡散して
いろんな環境いったよその内の1つがね私たちの
ご先祖様霊長類
もしですよ
今から6600万年前のあの恐竜絶滅させたあの隕石がですよ
軌道がそれっていたらどうでしょう
もしかしたら今でも恐竜時代だったかもしれないわけです
この大学のキャンパスに何とかザウルスが歩いてたかもしれない理由
逆にもっと大きい隕石が衝突していたらどうでしょう
恐竜も絶滅しましたけどもね私たちのご先祖様
霊長類も絶滅していくかもしれませんしもしかしたら全生命が
絶滅していたかもしれないわけですこれがわかりやすいね
先ほどね観ていただいた無数安心課のね
絵の中にある無数の偶然の一つなんです
つまり何が言いたいかというとですねまあどこかにいますよどこかには存在するけども
たっそんなにたくさんは存在してなる
かなりレイヤーな存在だということが
今のねあの
根拠ですね
どこまでまとめますね家のどこかには適正まきっと必ず存在しますでもそれは非常に
リアーナ存在ですよスーパーレイヤーな存在ですね
進化が難しいからですね知的生命までのねそういうことが9ここまでのねえ
我々が宇宙をね研究してきて分かったことです
もしですよ
ここからは想像ですもし
どこから良さの方針の住人がね私たちのこの地球を見ていたらここまでの話は見上げる
話だったんだけど今度ね
逆ですね視線を転換しますもし
よその住人が私たちの地球を見ていたらかエラーの目に私たちはどのように映るん
でしょうか
私たちは笑われておらはれてはいけない
そういうように思うわけですね
15歳から悩み続けてですねようやく今ね
答えが出たように私は思っています
地球人っていうのはですねあの大変に結局レアな存在ですよ
大変貴重な存在です
もし
私たちの隣の人が困っていたらですね
手を
足述べてあげようではありませんか
私たちはお互いに尊重し合い
協力し合う的なんじゃないかと思います
なぜならば私たちホモサピエンス私たち地球人は大変にレアーな
貴重な音存在なんです
一人一人はここにいらっしゃる皆さんもね youtube を見ている皆さん
一人一人はかけがえのない大切な存在なんです
一人一人が
奇跡の存在なんですどうもありがとう
[拍手]